[موسيقى
] يبدو الماء هنا على الشاطئ وكأنه أزرق
يذهب جاتوريد إلى مصر لأنني أقدم
عرضًا هنا لأول مرة في مصر
، أنا روس وأنا أعزف الموسيقى التي أحب هذه
المنطقة من العالم إنها تدور حول المشجعين
و  المعجبون الذين أحبهم مجرد جنون ، إنه
ملحمة لأن هناك الكثير من الحب هنا
وأعتقد أن لدي قاعدة جماهيرية كبيرة في
الشرق الأوسط لأنني ردت بالمثل
على الحب الذي أظهروه ، دعني
أعيد الحب وأحاول التخطيط لأكبر عدد من العروض
لا يمكن أن يكون هذا مكانًا بعيدًا حقًا
حيث صنعت الأغاني التي
أوصلتني إلى هنا ، لذا من الجيد جدًا أن
الكثير من الأشخاص بالخارج ينتظرون
الدخول وسنواصل العمل بمجرد تشغيل جميع
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الخاصة بي ، إنها نعمة  لأن
هذا هو سبب رؤيتي لجمهوري وهذا هو السبب في أنني
اكتشفت أن هذا أمر رائع حقًا
في مصر الآن لدينا خطة لعرض
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أوه ،
لقد نظرت في الحشد وكنت كما لو
كان كل شيء على الأرض  هؤلاء الأشخاص
هنا لم أزر مصر من قبل وها هم 8000
شخص لأول مرة لا أعرف
إنه جنوني تمامًا
[موسيقى]
كنت أعتقد دائمًا أن موسيقاي
ستصل إلى العالم لمجرد أنني
أؤمن برسالتي وأعتقد أن
كتابة الأغاني تتعلق بجعل الناس
يشعرون بأنهم ليسوا بمفردهم ، الأمر يتعلق
بجعل الناس يشعرون أنهم يستطيعون  افعل ذلك
أيضًا لأن رسالتي بأكملها هي
مجرد إيمان بالنفس بدلاً من ذلك ، فأنت تعرف حقًا نعم
فعلت هذا ، لكن هل يمكن أن تكون غاضبًا من
الوحل الذي قالوا إنني أنا الذي أصبح دي جي
أفعل لأنني أعلم أن هذا هو المكان
الذي تعرف فيه المعجبين  ما أقوله ،
نعم بالتأكيد سأعود